meine mama hat in der schule noch
schreibmaschinen schreiben gelernt hört
sich komisch an oder genauso komisch
könnte es sich irgendwann mal für meine
kinder anhören dass ich im
informatikunterricht das schreiben an
einer tastatur gelernt habe denn im
schnitt schafft man damit nur 60 wörter
pro minute während uns gehirn computer
schnittstellen wie zb der gehirn chip
den rohling entwickelt und theoretisch
an die grenzen von dem bringen könnten
was unser gehirn verarbeiten kann
800 wörter pro minute bis es soweit ist
und ich mich zu so einem quatsch
überreden lassen würde ist es allerdings
noch eine ganze weile hin in der wir
wahrscheinlich alle eine ganze menge
zeit sparen könnten wenn wir jetzt schon
mit einer tastatur doppelt so schnell
tippen können außerdem ist doch einfach
saucool schnell kippen zu können und ist
es immerhin viel schneller als morsecode
in schäbigen fördern pro minute und
genau das versuche ich diese woche also
nicht morsecode aber zehn finger system
lernen und herausfinden wie viel
schneller ich da durch tippen lernen
dieses video wird unterstützt von blink
ist höhere vorschlagen wir finden jetzt
mal raus womit wirst wenn mir überhaupt
zu tun haben wie schnell schreibt jemand
der die letzten 13 jahre seines lebens
den ganzen tag vom pcs leertaste startet
das diktat oh mein gott ich komm jetzt
die flashbacks
[Musik]
ok normale bewertung für wörter pro
minute errechnet sich aus den anschlägen
pro minute durch fünf heißt ich habe
hier 406 anschläge pro minute geteilt
durch fünf ist das 81,2 wörter pro
minute ist eigentlich schon in ort bett
für ein anfänger normal sind wohl mit
dem zehnfingersystem bei geübten
anwendern zwischen 200 und 300
anschlägen in der minute
ich habe jetzt 400 gemacht wikipedia
sagt hier die schreibleistung eines
durchschnittlichen zehn finger
schreibers liegt zwischen 200 und 300
anschlägen minute ich bin schon knapp
über 400 anschlägen und damit 80 gramm
pro minute und das ohne den finger
schreiben aber welche ganzen tag vor dem
pc sitzt was mich jetzt aber wirklich
interessieren würde ist wie viel luft
nach oben da noch ist wenn ich wirklich
zehn finger system könnte dafür
analysiere ich jetzt erstmal
zeitlupenaufnahmen meiner performance so
sieht das ganz normal aus und so langsam
wird es dann in st
also man sieht ihr direkt dass ich
einige finger regelmäßig benutzt aber
bei der rechten hand zum beispiel bei
diesem er jetzt benutze ich meinen
mittelfinger wo ich dafür eigentlich
schon meinen kleinen finger benutzte
benutzen hatte sollen sorgt dann hier
dafür dass ich beim komma hier in roten
fehler macht und generell wie man vor
allem ärzte aus dieser perspektive sieht
extrem ineffizient weil ich aber viel
länger braucht um zu überlegen und zu
sehen welchen nächsten knopf drücken
muss
[Musik]
hier waren zu gewinnen das heißt ich
benutze beim schreiben nur sieben finger
so richtig und nicht zehn schau dort
übrigens einen blauen mittelfinger ich
mache parallel noch ein experiment bei
dem ich malerei lerne und ölfarbe ist
echt hartnäckig ebenso hartnäckig sind
meine mittelmäßigen tipp gewohnheiten
die sich über jahre hinweg gefestigt
aber ich probiere jetzt einfach mal an
den text mit zehn finger system zu
schreiben die beiden zeigefinger kommen
auf elf von jos dafür aber noch übrigens
die ganz kleinen luxus hier wie so
häufig im leben ist es natürlich am
besten wenn man von klein auf eine sache
direkt richtig lernt denn bevor ich mit
dieser art zu schreiben schneller werde
werde ich erst mal viel langsamer als
normal unter zehn wörter pro minute
statt über 80 was großes b machen indem
man hier drauf dienen soll und dann ein
zeichen auch ob er schon wirklich kann
ich das überhaupt noch trainieren und
wie lange dauert es bis ich damit meine
sieben finger technik übertreffe ab
sofort werde ich nur noch mit zehn
fingern schreiben bis schlicht damit
schneller bin zum glück gibt es da für
software die einen genau bei bringen wo
jeder einzelne finger wirklich hingehört
wie man hier sieht sollten die beiden
kleinen kinder die ich aktuell noch so
gut wie gar nicht benutze im optimalfall
nämlich die größte fläche der tastatur
abdecken werden sich die ringfinger nur
um jeweils vier tasten kümmern müssen
schreib training starten jetzt mir erst
mal nur asdfjkl82 jetzt schon richtige
wäre dann also die basics zu lernen das
ist schon eine starke methode glaube ich
um das schnell effiziente sich
einzuprägen und expekt die ganze danach
links und wenn er dann auf sich zu
bewegen dann ist es mega gottes
täuschung wo ich dreh durch das ist wald
macht was find ich cool dass ein kleines
system am ende des ersten tages bin ich
bei lektionen neue in einem sogenannten
intelligenten diktat mit so extrem
intelligenten setzen wie der joker joggt
oder ja zwischenstand 124 anschläge
beziehungsweise 25 wörter pro minute
ich habe jetzt tag 2 und mein training
beginnt jetzt gleich nachdem ich das
intro für eines meiner nächsten videos
gescriptet hat und ich bin durch das
zehnfingersystem direkt viel produktiver
geworden
[Musik]
weiter geht's mit dem training ich hoffe
das ziel jetzt an weil sonst kommt man
mal einen tipp geschwindigkeit nur noch
einmal monaten wie der grund warum ich
mein text schreiben also e mails usw
nicht einfach meine alte schnelle
technik verwendet ist dass ich dadurch
meine alten muster aufrechterhalten
würde wäre nicht mehr neu aneignen
ähnlich verlockend wäre es natürlich im
spanisch sprach urlaub auf das für einen
selbst viel leichtere englisch
zurückzugreifen was seinen fortschritt
allerdings ordentlich ausbremsen würde
es für sie richtig handeln keinen finger
diese tasten zu drücken so was ist mir
die kraft gefehlt aber ich merke wie ich
richtig schnell lernen also es fühlt
sich an als würde ich direkt unter
meinen fingerspitzen neuen nervenzellen
bilden
vielleicht soll ich eine pause machen
zwischenstand 199 anschläge
beziehungsweise 40 wörter pro minute
ich bin auch mega war dann aber jetzt
heißt durchbeißen jetzt aufgefallen dass
ich beim abtippen diese spannenden
texten wie zum beispiel die spinne von
christian fürchtegott gellert aus god
damn 1946 ja dass diese texte ich beim
lesen durch seine augen durch andere
direkt wieder rausgehen das heißt ich
war jetzt neben dem training einfach
hörbücher oder musik
[Musik]
nach wissensstand 310 einschläge
beziehungsweise 62 wörter pro minute an
tag 3 tag 4 zieht vorbei wie in trance
357 1 schläge pro minute tag 5 über
diese woche hinweg wird jedes einzelne
wort und jede einzelne bewegung beim
tippen um trainiert ich bin dabei
tatsächlich schneller wenn ich aufhöre
versuche mit dem kopf nachzudenken was
ich drücken muss sondern einfach machen
und dann kann sich und seiner masse
memory dabei förmlich beim lernen zu
sehen an tag 5 habe ich aber scheinbar
ein plateau erreicht bei mittlerweile
362 anschlägen pro minute also nur noch
zwölf prozent entfernt von dem was ich
mit meiner alten technik erreicht habe
dadurch merke ich im alltag dass ich
automatisch auch außerhalb des trainings
beim richtigen system bleibe weil ich
nicht mehr das gefühl habe dass es mich
stark bremst aber mein ziel erreicht
habe ich damit noch nicht
301 schläge pro minute irgendwie
[Musik]
gmbh und dem speed altar ich würde
eigentlich sagen ich hab' geborgenheit
auch ist es vom management experten ich
hab kein bock mehr wenn ich nicht mal
gedacht habe aber ich hab voll bock
warum ich jetzt versehen im wald bin
weiß ich auch nicht auf jeden fall kann
ich jetzt deutlich schneller schreiben
ich meine ich hatte auch besser
geschrieben mit der technik wenn nicht
einfach ein bisschen mehr gibt weiter so
wie ich es getan habe allerdings habe
ich jetzt viel viel viel mehr luft nach
oben mit dieser technik und ja ich
schreibe private sowieso nicht groß und
klein aber noch alles klein und dann bin
ich noch mal ein gutes stück schneller
und das ist schon mal klar da sind echt
geiler als kind war ich schnell drin nur
eine woche ich glaube auch nicht dass
ich das auch mal verlieren hat richtig
spaß gemacht da ich habe vor allem
schnell hinten in der schule auch
komplett gehasst und ist schon geil ich
konnte mich in einer woche ordentlich
verbessern drastisch verändern wenn sich
die geschwindigkeit mit der menschen mit
computern interagieren aber erst wenn es
gehirn implantate für sowas gibt also
zum beispiel das woran ihr denn max
firma derzeit arbeitet auch wenn man ins
projekte mit tesla spacex und neweling
für ein bisschen verrückt oder sogar wo
sie halten mag kann ich nur jedem seiner
biografie also lebensgeschichte
empfehlen bei brink ist unserem heutigen
sponsor gibt es das und viel mehr als
hörbuch in voller länge zum nebenbei
hören also unterwegs oder im haushalt
ein alleinstellungsmerkmal von blink ist
ist es jedoch dass man dort den
kerninhalt von tausenden büchern auch
extrem verdichtet und komprimiert
serviert bekommt zum beispiel in 13
stunden gesamtlänge gibt es wirklich
wichtigste auch in ungefähr 15 minuten
zum lesen oder anhören oder in
siebeneinhalb minuten mit anhören im
zweifachen tempo also ein absolutes muss
wenn ihr wenig zeit habt aber trotzdem
wissbegierig zeit oder euch einfach
weiterentwickeln möchte jetzt mit
unzähligen büchern zu den themen
wissenschaft technologie
persönlichkeitsentwicklung
unternehmertum und viel mehr könnt euch
jetzt den kompletten überfluss von
lebensverändernden wissen eine woche
lang komplett kostenlos auf linke.de /
pommery und das noch bevor ihr ein
jahres abo abschließt wenn ihr euch dann
denkt
das brauche ich in meinem leben dann
erhaltet ihr 25 prozent rabatt auf das
jahres-abo flinkes premium erster link
in der video beschreibung link fsd.de
stommel und damit verabschiede ich mich
letzte woche gab es mal am samstag ein
video warum das so ist erfahrt ihr über
das zweite video hier in der end karte
oder auch in der beschreibung und dann
würde ich sagen
aber jetzt keines kanal 9c man zunächst
mal wieder
[Musik]